les 30 ministres des Affaires étrangères
membres de l'OTAN réunis en Roumanie
pour aider l'Ukraine à passer l'hiver
cela fait plus de 9 mois que la gare a
commencé qui a fait plus que jamais
besoin de ses alliés
les alliés de l'OTAN apportent un
soutien sans précédent et aujourd'hui
ils ont pris des engagements
supplémentaires dans le cadre du plan
global d'aide de l'OTAN à l'Ukraine
cela comprendra à la fourniture urgente
d'équipement non Léto comme du carburant
et des générateurs pour aider l'Ukraine
à faire face aux conséquences des
frappeuses contre son réseau électrique
et les besoins sont considérables 25 à
30% des infrastructures énergétiques ont
déjà été endommagées par les frappes
russes l'hiver lui est déjà bien
installé certaines régions enregistrent
des températures négatives et on
s'attend à des moins 30 degrés dans les
prochaines semaines
la dernière fois que j'ai été à la
réunion ministérielle de l'OTAN je suis
venu avec trois mots des armes des armes
et des armes
aujourd'hui j'ai trois mots différents
ce sont des
syriennes pour neutraliser des missiles
des drones et autres menaces des
systèmes pour entre autres protéger les
sites énergétiques des frappes russes
l'OTAN ne fournit pour l'instant pas
d'équipement l’état la l'Ukraine pour
éviter toute escalade avec la Russie
mais ce mardi chacun de leur côté
certains alliés membres de l'OTAN ont
fait des gestes importants 500
générateur et 2000 tentes adaptées aux
conditions hivernales pour l'Union
européenne une aide financière de 53
millions de dollars de la part de
Washington de son côté la France et
l'Allemagne sont déjà en train d'envoyer
des centaines de générateurs électriques